welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
today we will learn about my SQL
connector for python that said if these
are the type of videos you'd like to
watch then hit that like And subscribe
button and the bell icon to get notified
just for a quick info if you want to
upscale yourself master business
analytics and landar your dream job or
grow in your career then you must
explore simply learn's cohort of various
business analytics programs simply learn
offers post graduate programs from CD
University in collaboration with Amazon
Google and Microsoft through this
program you will gain knowledge and work
expertise in skills like prescriptive
and Predictive Analytics regression
classification and over a dozen others
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
learn from industry experts and Top Tire
product companies and academicians from
top universities after completing these
courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into a business Analytics
Ro as a fresher or moved onto a higher
paying job profile if you are passionate
about making your career in this field
then make sure to check out the link in
the pin comment and description box
below to find out the business analytics
program that fits your experience and
areas of Interest now without further
delay let's get started with the
demonstration for today's session so the
onepoint agenda that is my SQL connector
for python now let's check on the codes
that we are going to execute for the day
so technically we have the three major
codes but in case if you have the uh
MySQL connector for python existing in
your windows you can then you can also
uh unlist or uninstall that but majorly
three major codes check for the python
version if you have you can proceed then
check or start python idle and try to
execute the last code and if case if in
case if you get an error that means you
don't have it and then you can come back
to the second line and install the code
from command prompt and then go back to
idal and you can get started or you can
also import this into your IDE that's
said let's get started with the
demonstration let me start the command
prom there you go the command prom got
successfully started let's check the
python version we have python hyphen
hyphen we have it it is python
3.11.0 fine now let's check the P list
if I already have that my SQL connector
in the Leone mod so I think yes we do
have the python connector now let's
quickly uninstall it you can use the
same code uh
pip
uninstall this paste it done you can
quickly uninstall that just give yes now
it's been remove if I check the PIP list
again we will not have it right now we
will use the same code to install it
okay before that let's check python idle
right here we have the
idle if we
check
Cod my SQL do
connector we should be getting an error
right so now let's go back to
the command prompt and use this code to
install it back again remember you have
to write pip install we have already
uninstalled it
so C installed my SQL connector for
python enter now the file should be
downloading successfully got installed
now now let's go back to python idle and
execute the same code once again and we
should not get any errors indicating the
presence of my SQL connector for python
present there you go you have no more
errors so that's how you install MySQL
connector for python in Windows
operating system and with that we have
come to another session on MySQL
connector for python in Windows and if
you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session or if
you require any resources that we used
in this session like PP please do let us
know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be happy to
help you as soon as possible until next
time thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from Simply learn staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upscaling whether you're a
student student aiming to learn today's
top skills or a working professional
looking to advance your career we've got
you covered explore our impressive
catalog of certification programs in
cuttingedge domains including data
science cloud computing cyber security
AI machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here